Okay, so we are recording now, and it was like last time, really, really, just a state of
name and a date date.
Yeah, my name is Kenneth Hedberg, and what else you want?
A date date.
A date today?
Yeah.
Oh, and this is September 20, 2011.
So we last thought, last time you had just made the switch over to there, and she made
her, and that he was starting to research with him, and I wanted to think, well, this
is about how that happened, how he meant to make her, and, yeah, this is that Celtic.
I can't remember, although I mentioned that I spent a year working with Garden of Swain.
I think I did that, yeah.
Well, at the end of that time, I interviewed Werner Schumerker, who might pass them all several
times in the other group of people, he was young, not far from my age, so I went to see
him.
We hit it off.
Well, I decided I would do my future work with him, and I began almost immediately,
and we decided we would look at a number of boron compounds that we were able to, we
didn't make them ourselves, we got them from a guy at USC, who is named, I can't remember
now, distinguished in Jordan, I can't list today, right?
Every began with Diaboraine, which we measured, and we're able to show conclusively that
it was a non-ethane like structure, it had two iterations up above and below the boron
boron bond, and the well-known bridge structure.
After that, we took up a number of other boron compounds, including, before H10, B5H9, B5H11,
and some substituted Diaboraine with clined and bromine atoms, all of them, and also amino
groups, amino Diaboraine, we studied, all of these took place in the next few years,
I think some of them overlap, I was still working when some of them after I got my degree
when I continued, so that was a exciting time, and excuse me, I finished my degree in June
of 1948, and I was offered a post-doctoral position, oh, that came about an interesting
way, Paul and came around one time in spring of 1947, that was only, or maybe it was a
fall of 1947, I don't have been there for at most 18 months, and he said, I think you
should write up your work for a degree, and I said, well, I was hoping I would be able
to take another year, and work that year with Professor Badger, who is a distinguished
spectroscopist, Paul and said to me, well, he says, you write up your thesis and did a
degree, and I'll say that you get a fellowship, so you can spend an extra year working
with Dick Badger, and then you said, you know, you'll make a lot more money, have to
get your degree, then you would before you get your degree, so why not, you're studying
doesn't stop at the time you get your degree, so the logic of this is impeccable, and
I said about writing up my work for my thesis, and I'm sorry about this throat, I have
the same problem last time, so I finished writing up my thesis, now the troublesome aspect
of this is that my supervisor, Werner Schemaker, was off on the Guggenheim Fellowship,
and Denmark, and so the person that nominally oversaw my research was Robert Kory.
Robert Kory, of course, he unpolling published a series of seven papers, and ultimately
led to polling, winning them Nobel Prize, or his alpha helix, and other things as well.
Anyway, Bob Kory didn't know anything about the lecture on the fraction, but he was a very
nice, friendly man, and he helped me over some crucial points, so I'm having a lot of trouble
writing this thesis, getting it all right, he says, well, he says, tell me what it is,
you're struggling with, and so I told him he says, why don't you write it down?
So I wrote down what I had been telling him, and then it's a little bit, and I don't
me over at home.
Anyway, I finally finished my thesis and took my examination.
Polling was not present in Werner, it was not present either, having a still being in Denmark,
so excuse me.
After I got my degree, I continued to work for a while until on the projects that I had
been working until Werner returned Denmark, and then I was sure enough I've got my degree
polling returned, and I received notice that I had been awarded an A noise fellowship,
which enabled me to spend a year working with Richard Badger, which I did, and I learned
some spectroscopy in that year, but on the side, I continued my work in electron diffraction
as well, but that was a very nice year.
At the end of my fellowship year, I was appointed a research fellow at Caltech, and I worked
on a grant that Werner Schumacher had with the Office of Naval Research.
At that time, the Office of Naval Research was sponsoring basic research, and I didn't
have to have much to do with the Navy as far as I could make up, but so I worked on that
for a couple of years, and then in 1951, I think it was polling said to me, oh, maybe I should
go back to step. During this year, a number of people showed up at Caltech from abroad, mostly
postdoctoral people who were anxious to work, either with polling or some other
dignitary, and water too, with Werner Schumacher, and I became quite friendly with a number
of these people, including a guy from Norway, in the Altobustelnson.
I'm getting just a little ahead of the story there, but because I decided after I'd had a
couple of years that I should have a postdoctoral fellowship, maybe abroad or something like that,
so I decided that I would continue my work in spectroscopy, and so I filled out an application
for a full bright fellowship to Belgium. There was a band there with whom I wanted to work,
and so I filled this thing out, sent it all off, and got back a notice and due course a few
months later, something unfortunately. My application had been received too late to be considered
in that year's batch of full bright fellows, but they urged me to apply again for the following year.
Well, in the following year, my friend Altobustelnson, later friend, Altobustelnson showed up from Norway,
and he was a specialist in electro and defraction, and I had no name not personally, but through
publications, and we hit it off, we became very friendly, my wife and myself, and him and his wife,
and he had two small daughters, and so we worked together at Caltech for a while, and then as a year
of due to a close, he said, why don't you apply again for a full bright and apply this time to go to Norway,
instead of to Belgium? I said, well, that sounds to me, like it might be worthwhile,
maybe I'll do that. About the same time, Pauling walked into my office one day and said to me,
I think you should apply for a cooking high and fellowship. This is how he didn't say,
would you like to? He said, I think you should do this.
Well, Pauling carried such an oral within that when he made it suggesting, you almost always follow through,
and decide that was a prestigious fellowship, and so I thought I'd go up and said, okay, well I'll do that,
so I wrote out an application form, which was essentially the same proposal for research
that I had written to the full bright program, and I sent this off, and I waited around a while,
working away with my her, not knowing what was going to happen, the meantime,
Paul's Johnson went back to Norway, and in due course, I got a letter from the full bright people,
saying that I had been awarded a full bright research fellowship to go to Norway,
and this paid all my living expenses and paid my transportation back and forth.
And then about that same time, maybe a little later, Pauling walked into my office and said to me,
well, are you getting ready to go to Norway? He didn't know anything about my having received
the full bright fellowship, and I said, well, I didn't know I was going, and I think I may have the
chronology inverted here a little bit. I think maybe he came in before I received notice of the
full bright fellowship, that makes a little more sense, and I said, I didn't know I was going,
he said, well, the selection committee generally follows my recommendations, and he turned and walked out.
That's all, that was a total conversation we had on the issue. And a bit later,
I got a letter from the good and high in people, saying I had been awarded a good and high
fellowship to go to Norway, and it was $3,500. Well, now, and then the full bright notice occurred,
and then I had gone from where I had no support, where I had two rather well-indowed fellowships
for the same period, so I thought, well, you know, I have to let them know. So I wrote off to the
Guggenheim people, said, I'd also been awarded a full bright fellowship research fellowship. They said,
the Guggenheim money was given to me irrespective of whatever other words or money I had.
Well, I thought pretty good about that, so well, of course, I set the same letter to the
whole light people, and they wrote back after a while, and said, we normally subtract
money from additional grants from the full bright grant, but that, the amount of money that you have
from the other source should be enough to support you for the full period of your time before we
will take any action on this. And they said, we have determined that the $3,500, this is in
1940, 1952, that went a long way then, that $3,500 is not enough to support you in Norway for
a full 12 months, so we will not subtract it from them after we give you for the full bright grant.
Well, a full bright grant was a equivalent of a little more money than that, actually. I can't
remember what it was in Croner. I think it was $4,200 a month, and there were seven Croner to
a dollar then, so that was about $600 a month, so that might have been $75,000. I don't know,
$10,000 bucks in those days are big bucks. Well, at this time, my first life decided that she met
somebody she preferred to me, and so she let me, and I had all this money, and it was going to go
to Norway with as a single person. So, so I booked passage on Mauritania and I traveled across the
country, visited a couple of laboratories, I went to Oak Ridge and visited some friends there,
went on to New York, sent my luggage on ahead, and due course I embarked on the Mauritania,
which took me to Southampton, and I spent a few days in England, and then I sent sail again
on another ship to Norway, and when I arrived there, this was an origin ship liner. I was
met up the pair by my friend, Altaboste, and some of the number of other people that I had met there.
I didn't mention that I had been to Norway once before, after I had met Boste Johnson, I went to an
international meeting in Stockholm, and on the way back, I stopped, so by and shadowed it in a
little bit about what we were going to do, and we had a big party. That was a fine party.
I can still remember it. I don't know whether I should go into the details,
but anyway, that was a great party, and so he and the friends, his friends and collaborators,
on the laboratory met me at the boat, and they had been looking for a place for me to live.
This is Norway in 1950, the October of 1952, first of October, and it was after the war,
and Norway had really begun to recover very much then. So they told me that they had found
an apartment, and they were ashamed to say it was terribly expensive, but they thought it might
suit me pretty well, because it was very close to shopping. I had a, let me call it a district anyway,
called my Ustuit, and I had a fine apartment there, and it was owned by an English woman who had
been separated or divorced from her husband, and she had gotten this apartment. She was going back
to England, where she came from originally, and was going to rent it out for a year or so. And it
cost my friends told me that some of much over price was $150,000, and $50,000 a month. That's $20.
Now $150,000, remember my first check was $4,200, and that paid my rent for the entire month.
And so anyway, I moved into this place, which was furnished. It had a kind of a couch for a bed,
but it was perfectly satisfactory, and had a kitchen, a bathroom all about kind of a studio arrangement,
where then walking, it's easy walking this and so the university up on the hill.
So I lived there, and I had determined before I left, and I was going to learn the language.
And my friends, Bosteonson, had been talking to the cultural attache at the embassy,
and to the people in charge of the Fulbrightrogram, and they had managed to find me a set of records
called, and those that no longer exist, and I think, extent, they're called Linguofone records,
and they got me, and they were 78s, and they got me old record player. A friend had one of those,
and so I could play these records on them, and they could hear their sounds. Along with these records,
came a book in this book out of picture on it, and it had the text that was spoken.
So the idea was that you put the record on, and the first lesson, of course, was almost
obvious, the words were, once that you could translate from English, you know, so very slowly,
the words were spoken on this page, and you could see the picture of what it was describing on the
facing page, and so I would look at this, and the spoken word would come to you,
and then the pause, and you were supposed to repeat after this, mimicking the accent,
but tonality as closely as you could. And so this, I later came to admire these records very much,
because at this same time, you saw the written language, you heard it spoken, and you had to speak it,
and there was no translation except in the picture. And believe it or not, this happened in
52, I can still recite lesson 1, 2, 3, almost by heart, because after you had gone through this thing,
there was another section where they were asked to question, relating to this, and you had to
had to respond to that. You see, it was quite remarkable, and an example of this, the first sentence,
was describing the picture, is decked out for media, Hansen. Now you can almost, let's say,
what that Norwegian is a language, which has almost the same word order as English.
That the odd means this is, and this is the family Hansen in this picture. And then I saw
best of all, sit there, E in, Lien is the grandfather is sitting in a walking chair.
And you could see that if you're not, the bottom is as best of all, so it's grandfather,
so you look in the picture, and there's an old man, you know, in the beard, and he's sitting,
sitting, you know, that right away, in E and in Lien, a story, or the other in the school is chair,
and Lien, it means rock or take. Anyway, that's just an example. And I went through every day,
I came back from the university, I would sit down, I would study, it's amazing. These things only
played for three minutes if you played them through. It took me an hour to an hour and a half to get through,
a single lesson doing everything they want to me to do. And in the morning, I went to the
university, and I would, my friends, you know, they knew I was doing this, and I could recite the whole
lesson to them, which caused proxism of laughter. One of my friends said, the guy, there were several
voices, as a lesson went on. The first was a man who had a, he was an origin, but he was
rector of the university at that time. And my friends swore, they could hear his voice speaking,
spoke to them, I didn't mimic this accent. Well, anyhow, when I first went up to the laboratory,
to meet Paul Stelinson in the work environment, and we talked, we knew what we were going to do.
He introduced me to his laboratory assistant, whose name was Lisa Smith-Eck,
and he said, she's only been working with the three months, but I think you two should work together
well, because I have administrative duties I'm occupied with also. So we engaged in this project
and Lisa and I worked on it together. Well, when I was introduced to her, I was ever so impressed,
because, of course, I was introduced in English on the first day or two, and she spoke to me in
English, and we had a conversation, and I later answered, well, have you spent any time in,
what did you learn your English? It's one I learned at school, I said, to have an
ship in the England of the States. Oh, no, no, she says I've never been in an English-speaking country.
It impressed me so much, and this is true to all these people, you know, you walk in, they've been
never been out of the country, they can talk to you in your language, which of us can do that here,
you know, it's almost impossible. Anyway, we worked together, and for two or three days, and then
I very interested in music, and they also fill him out a play-down town,
and I got on the tram one time, went down the town. Oh, I think, oh, in the first few days I was there,
I decided I needed to have my own car. There were very few cars and also at that time.
My history today is one of the busiest places in town. I mean, it's bumper to bumper getting
into the, when I lived there, it was rarely a car, and they were all pre-war things. The country was
so destitute, of so devoid of money, that cars were very, very hard to come by, but anyway,
I could buy a car. There were agencies there, but I had to pay for it in foreign currency,
and I had to agree to sell it. I mean, I had to agree to export the car.
At, it had a special license plate on it, in the case, I had a Q number on it, which means
owned by a foreigner, and then she didn't pay tax. So the upside of all this was sort of a solder car,
in the country at the end, tax would have to be paid on it, but that stage. Anyway, I bought this car.
So I drove a downtown, in order with somebody here a few weeks later, and
and as I walked in, they stood, they said, picking up our ticket as I was picking up mine.
So we sat together, enjoyed the symphony, and afterward I asked her, she'd like to have a
after concert snack. And so we went to a restaurant of famous place called Blooms that is still there,
and we had a big cheese spread and had a good time together. We again date regularly.
And the episode of all that was, so after my year there, I went back to the states,
and there was a reason I were thinking of getting married, and I wasn't quite ready to commit,
because I hadn't quite recovered from my first marriage. But at any rate, I got back to the states,
and then I proposed to her, and I came back to following somewhere, which is 54,
and we were married in Oslo. And that, say, 54, I guess, has now been married 57 years,
and so anyhow, that was a romantic outcome. And I got, I've often speculated about this later,
suppose that full-bright application that I had applied for at a Holland to Belgium had been
successful. My life would have been quite different from what it is now. So it's such things
the fate turns on. How do you mean marrying a fair foreigner? Her mother had died a couple of years
before I arrived. She had a sister, and a father, a father, worked in a bank,
a personal manager of a bank, and she had an off the sister of her mother that lived upstairs
in the apartment building. My wife's family is going back to generations as a distinguished one.
They came from Denmark, and my wife's great-grandfather was the foreign minister of Denmark.
And he and his one of his siblings founded essentially the New York Times of Denmark,
it's called Pulla Ticken. And so the family had an interest in that newspaper.
One of the other brothers was the distinguished newspaper, my name is Critic.
The name is well-known. It's called Brandis Edvard Brandis. You can find books written about the
Brandis family in Denmark. Well, that was her great-grandfather and great-grandfather. Great-grandfather.
So anyway, these are the mother stemmed from this group,
has did her aunt upstairs who became kind of a surrogate mother to her as after her own mother died.
So we came back at least as father. I enjoyed him a lot. He was very taciturn. Some Norwegians don't
say very much, but I think he was pleased that I could speak to him in his language. He could
speak a few words in some words of English, but he wasn't as comfortable in it.
So we hit it off very well. And at least it's out too. She was a patrician type person.
He had beautiful furniture and paintings and so on. And her husband was a distinguished Norwegian
scholar and so on. Very well-peed. And this family, Lisa's aunt, Uncle, and her cousin to whom she
is still very close. You see them go out often. They have a lot of fancy stuff. They have paintings
by to lose her track and they have monk originals, Edward Monk, watercolors, and rippocrats,
and so on in their house. That was just something on the wall when I would, I would put him
in the press by a lot. So after we were married, I, no, we married in the city hall in Norway.
You haven't been in Norway, had you? No, well, they have a absolutely beautiful city hall.
And it's got marvelous paintings around huge murals on the wall that depict the
developing and evolution of the Norwegian nation. And outside, they have some carved huge
carved wooden figures from north-most north mythology. Wooden is there on his eight-legged horse with
two ravens ahead. All in wood, you can see up there. So, no, we were married. These had
arranged the license before I arrived and we were married in this office. It was a civil wedding.
I'm not sure, but I think as far as I know, a lot of the Norwegian weddings have done in that
fashion, at least, of the generation that Lisa stems from. So after we were married, we
fussed around a while because we had to get a visa for her. And that's a story which is
irreplace me still. So we apply for a visa down at the embassy. And the embassy is very worried
that there are foreigners that want to marry an American citizen simply to get into the country.
And you have to jump through a whole bunch of hoops and time went on one week, turn to two, turn
into three, and so on. And no word, no word at all. And so I finally wrote to a friend of mine that
I had met at Caltech and then was working a scientist working in Washington and I explained the
situation to him and he pulled some strings and discovered that the application was sitting on a
desk someplace in a pile of papers and they were working through and they would get to it. So
I virtually blew my top of this because here I am sitting in Oslo and not getting paid because I'm
not working waiting for some secretary to clear my application for Lisa. So I wrote to my congressman
in Pasadena. And he wrote back on the other dismissal, dismissal letter saying we have to make absolutely
certain that these marriages are not marriages of convenience. And you can imagine how I felt about
he was a conservative Republican, appropriately turned me into a Democrat forever. But anyhow,
eventually we got a visa, we got on the plane, flew to Washington, spent a night there
and went on the Pasadena. And my wife was very tired at this time and discouraged and one, you know,
Norway had beautiful atmospheric conditions. You could breathe deeply in the sky was clear
and we landed in a heavy, small time in LA and she later said she felt like getting right back
on the next plane and going home without experience. But so we stayed there and I went back to work
at Caltech as a senior research fellow now and I'll continue until I learned about the job at
Oregon State. Now, shall I go on to that? No, it was Dick Badger. I did a lecture on the
fraction, which you make, or which is a different technique. Some people call it electrons,
but it's not. I'm sorry. It's a separate discipline, but it's similar to the crystallography
in the sense that you measure a diffraction pattern. The diffraction patterns are very,
very different because I'm looking at molecules on the gas and x-ray diffraction looks at molecules
and it is in a crystal or at least in a condensed phase. How would you classify your discipline
well, how do you mean classified? It's a technique for studying the sizes and shapes of individual
molecules. A physical chemistry with infrastructure chemistry. Oh, I see. Well, when I was a
Caltech, as I say, I started doing organic reaction mechanisms for a year, then I did electron
diffraction. And in the course of this, I did some crystal structure, a crystal structure with
two other people and then I did spectroscopy with Dick Badger, so I had four different experiences
there. Now, this is a little unusual because at this institution, it's rare that a student works
from more than one person, of course, of getting his or her degree. Usually, you pick a supervisor
and you work on his projects and what up at thesis in your out of here. But I worked and in my thesis,
the Badger work, of course, I was a post-altural fellow at that time. But in the course of
getting my degree, I did three things that all of these things were written up in my thesis in
different sections. That's a little unusual. Probably a little unusual for Caltech, too, in that
people often do two different things, but three with three different people is quite different.
I don't know whether I mentioned that that crystal structure was very interesting. It had to do
with a compound called arcenyl benzene, which has a formula with, I can describe verbally,
as two benzene rings and two arsenic atoms. It was generally thought that the benzene rings
are hooked to the arsenic atoms and two arsenic atoms are joined together by a double bond
as we say in the language. But it was pretty well understood at that time that arsenic doesn't
like the form double bonds, very, very readily. And particularly with a compound like this,
where there's no opportunity, for example, in no oxygen, surround the form, no balloons.
So it was widely thought to be a dimer, the one I described just two units hooked together.
But we suspect that that wasn't true. And so when we looked at it, we found that there actually
was a six-member ring of arsenic atoms with these benzene rings flopping off. One off of each
arsenic atom. So it was a hexamer relay and a very nice molecule. The interesting thing about this
is many years later, I got a photocopy on our large photocopy, which I still have.
This was before a year old, became the official currency of Europe. I have a 200 mark German
bank note. Now 200 marks was a big bucks in those days. And on it, it's a picture
of a man who is responsible for discovering the first arsenic holes in use for treating
cyplos in particular. Well, one of the arsenic holes used was, I gather was our senomancing
because on this bank note, our paper is actually cited with the three authors and the
date, which happens to be wrong, but at any rate, it's on the face of the bank note.
I thought that was once upon it. So anyway, that's what I did at Caltech.
And I call myself a structure chemist. So the thing that led me into electron diffraction was
that to realize this was 50 odd years ago now. It was kind of a cutting edge technology.
It was the best way everything considered of determining the sizes and shapes and motions
of individual molecules that are unaffected by the presence of others.
A crystal structure across the molecules that will pack together.
And the other technique that works also on the same phase is micro-inspiracroscopy.
But in order for micro-inspiracroscopy to succeed, it has to molecule, it has to have a dipole moment,
and a lot of them don't. Our senomancing, for example, would not have. So you can't study a lot of things,
but we can study anything we can get into the gas phase, select on the fraction. So
I decided I would continue with that work, because I like what I was doing with Schumaker at Caltech,
and that's what got me started.
So you mentioned Schumaker and Korean, and it's just been knowing a little bit more about what they were
like, because there's now either like to do something about it socially.
Well, I can tell you, well Schumaker, in my way of thinking he was a brilliant scientist,
but not aggressive in the sense that he pushed like a lot of people do.
You know, in science, it is always enough to have talent. You have to be a salesman as well.
And people like Linus Pauling, he is a tremendous salesman, because he had a personality
that took him the whole room, so he had a sense of humor in his lectures,
were very, very heavily attended. People come from miles around to hear him, and I've heard him
lecture to packed halls in several foreign countries. There are other people who are distinguished
also, but have a very tiring personality. And some of these are one noble prizes, you know,
but they don't have the public acclaim that a person like Pauling does, or augment the
way on those from Caltech. And these guys sell themselves, and they're other people too.
So Schumaker was a brilliant scientist and a very critical thinker.
He was amazing in that respect. He was so highly regarded that Pauling used to come down and
bounce his ideas off of Schumaker. He would come into the office and talk to Schumaker and say,
verner, what do you think of this? And he would describe something. And other people, the
organic chemists from the third floor of Caltech, names are getting harder for me to come
by quickly would come down, talk to him about there is problems they had. And he was like a
bulldog. He couldn't let go of a problem. He would analyze it, turn it around, upside down, and if
this, that, et cetera, these people were sitting and listening very carefully to him. So that's
a kind of guy I was. He also, we went hiking and I see our backpacking together. We became
close personal friends, as well as my, me being a student. So we did hikes in the high sea areas
on a couple of occasions. I used to go every summer for any one to two weeks backpacking
in the high sea area. So we would do that. And he was eager and interested in that.
There are a host of interesting events, but you see I'm not quite sure how much of this
I should go into, but let me talk about Torrey. Torrey was a, he was a very nice man and he
helped me a great deal when Schumacher wasn't there in that last year when I was riding up my
faces. And he was a Chris Logifer and I don't remember the detail, so I won't try to recite them,
but I've read them. You can get them the archives, Celtic archives, tell all about polling,
so encountering Torrey and inviting him to come to Celtic. So then he, he suffered from some
kind of a nervous disorder. It was not Parkinson's, in that he had some ticks that would cause
his whole arm to move a little bit. And when he walked, he walked sometimes with a little bit
of motion. I'm not quite sure what it was, but that was not evident in a speech when you talked
to him. And when he was sitting down, you didn't see any Parkinson's like motion at all from him.
But he would come to see me and I could see him in a time I wanted. He was responsible for a very large
excuse me, laboratory. He was headed up by a guy who is making compounds of the sort that
polling was interesting and that played a role ultimately in his formulation of the alpha helix.
So I don't know much more about him than just that, but to this day I'm very grateful for
what he did for me in the time of chimpanzees. Yes, Dan was a very nice guy too,
any other very nice wife. I knew Dan Campbell quite well because there was a very free
social order at Celtic. All kinds of parties with the students, postdocs, and the faculty,
you have a student party, you know, and everybody would be invited and Dick Badger would show up
with his wife and Dan and his wife would show up and others as well. Polling didn't come to these
parties far as I know. I don't remember ever seeing him there, but I do remember a number of them
in which people from physics can Dick Feynman showed up in a number of these. I've heard Feynman play
his bundle drums that these bodies. So Campbell was a nice guy. He had a medical problem which
was sold, he had colon cancer and lay removed the large tumor from his colon. But I don't think
he ever suffered a recurrence of that. He was what was called an immuno chemist and that was
something the polling was interested in at the time and you know chemistry. So does that answer
your question about what I knew about Campbell? Do you ever manage in speed rather than hearing?
Yes, but only in passing. Roger Hayward of course was illustrating polling books for
him. And he had a number of beautiful figures and various books, but only in passing. I just
met him. I never had a chance to talk with him. Do you? Yes.
Yeah, I guess you told me that last time. I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about Jack
and then the person in also why is he important in my sight? Oh, well, I didn't talk about
Jack before, did I? No. Jack was became a very, I just to this day, a very good friend of mine.
He has showed up after getting his degree at in Scotland with Jam Robertson and he came to Caltech
and in the British system, you know, when you study for a PhD, you do your undergraduate work,
you study for a PhD. But my understanding is you don't do much coursework from that point on.
So, Jack attended lectures at Caltech. You see on subjects that he had an interest in that
he had not been exposed to before. But we worked together a little bit, we published a paper
to together and Jack has absolutely incredible sense of humor and he could do, I don't know,
he's not a pushy guy. It's kind of a laid-back lie sense of humor, you know, but he's not a
retiring individual at all. He's a very social guy. He's just not a pushy social guy.
So, he came to Caltech and he was working on crystallography on electron defraction and
then he was joined by, I won't say he was joined, but another guy came named Leslie Ordle.
And Jack and Leslie became very good friends. Leslie died recently, but he was a distinguished
scientist. He was a theoretical chemist to begin with, but began turned to
molecular biology later on and went to the salt institute and had a distinguished career there.
Jack, when Pauling one is Nobel Prize for Chemistry in 54, we had a huge big, and then we put together
let's call it a review in the vault of Elfona thing where there are lots of skits and songs and
there was a talented fellow named Ted Harold also from Britain who could write music and
played the piano and he composed a lot of stuff. And among other things that were composed for little
acts or a participant would do a kind of monologue and Jack was involved in one of these.
It's a famous one. The whole thing has been recorded and you probably have a copies of it here.
It's called a road to Stockholm. In there there is something where one of the individuals
sitting in his laboratory looking out the window at the young girls going by in front of a cold
Bunsen. If you haven't heard that record, it should be put on tape or disc because it's on
Shalak and homemade and it tends to deteriorate. So Jack participated in things like that.
The young lady came and they began to go together. Her name was Daphne. I don't remember her
her last name. But anyway they became very close and they came engaged to be married.
She was a postdoctoral person working in biology and they had met at one of these social occasions. I guess
they were together a lot and groups, big parties, all of us were. And then Jack's period
Daphne went home and Jack's period of Celtic ended and he went home and then it turned out
that she had decided against the marriage and broke the engagement.
Well, Jack at this time was working with Dorothy Hotskin and Anne Oksford and I was on a trip to Europe
for some meeting or another and I stopped buying visitors with Jack and he told me that there was
really a hard thing for him. But it turned out Daphne never married after that. We not quite sure
in the reason that they broke up. It's a little obscure but I can say this at least as a rumor.
She decided that Jack was Jewish and she was not and this conflict was just conflict apparently
with something she decided she couldn't live with. And anyway, a year or two later
Jack met another young woman. His present wife, his name is Barbara and he met her in black
wells at Oxford. She was where she was. I don't know what her background is but she was working
in the store there and black wells and they hit it off immediately. She's a beautiful girl and they
were married and they have I think they have two children. So Jack, at the end of this period
in Britain, you may have a list on record but you want me to tell you what I know about it.
His future career was, Dorothy Hodgkin, of course, had worked in the structure of vitamin B12
and had determined its structure and had presented this as a plenary electorate of meeting
from her half of the bill and she got a standing ovation for this and she later won the Nobel Prize for
her work. Well, this lecture or other work that she had been doing with organic molecules and
pressed the people in the organic, I don't know whether it's a college or a school or whatever
division, if they ate it in Zurich and they asked her to recommend somebody who could
to be in organic chemistry, who could determine structures and she recommended Jack.
Well, he went there, gave a lecture, showed what he was doing and the
upshot of all this, let's say hired him as a faculty member. Well, he's had a distinguished career
there, he's just widened his horizons immensely, became a professor, which in the old German
system is about the equivalent of the well-regarded senator in this country. And spinach's
entire career in Zurich is now retired, but I think he still has an office although I'm not sure
what he's doing. Occasionally, I want to cross them in this country and I write to him occasionally also.
So, he is his reputation, grew by leaps and bounds, he's a foreign associate of the National Academy
of Sciences and he gave the Baker lectures at Cornell, let's say in lecture series of polling
gave that resulted in this book, the Nature the Chemical Pond. So, Jack's had a wonderful career,
he's a very, very nice man. Well, it's a little hard to tell, major discoveries in a scientific sense.
He has a lot of distinguished publication record, not an amount, but the sorts of things that he took
up and studied thoroughly, basic sciences, very helpful to others. But I don't fall across the
log a few very closely, so I can't tell you much about what he has done. I do know that he worked
very hard on the confirmations of rings of various members in the rings. There is elements of
the rings, 5, 6, 7, 8, and my rings, and so on. He's well known for that.
I like to talk about calling it for a little bit. It doesn't sound like the, it sounds like you
was certainly a person who spent time with others, but it often sounds like it's not the
name for a social way. Yes, well, he wasn't anti-social at all. It's just that
the kinds of parties that I'm describing that many, but not all, the faculty attended,
like, oh, I'm trying to think, for example, you mentioned Dan Campbell and Dick Badger and Werner
and a number of other faculty members, as well as postdocs and graduates, so they'd all
have a big party, you know, everybody was on a first name basis. I never called Badger by anything
other than his first name. Even as a student, that's how he was known. Almost everybody was on
a first name basis, except the polling. He was always not to polling. He sort of
carries an oral with him and all the way is friendly enough. You know, you didn't, you only came
so far. He always called me by my first name, even on visits around here. I never really
called him by his first name, but then he, any comfort at all, because he never invited it.
Now, I should tell you something, this is kind of a, doing back to my stay in Norway.
The person who headed up the laboratory on that first one, there was a man named old hustle.
He later won the Nobel Prize. Housel was a, is a lawyer, if I tell a little bit about hustle.
He was an interesting man in the Norwegian system. They had professorships just like the
German system. He was a professor of physical chemistry and there was a professor of organic chemistry
groups. But Housel was unique. He was virtually, I don't know if I could call him an alphabet,
oh, but he had very light features, very light hair, and he was very, he had kind of in the
stagmas, and he had trouble reading. He never married, and he had a lot of money for the
inherited. He was a very good scientist. During the war, he was very aggressive, and he was
imprisoned along with a couple of other people, and they were kept in a camp in Oslo. They were
now allowed the teach. The university was closed, but in against all regulations in this camp,
Housel organized a series of lectures and studies, so the imprisoned people that are actually
learned a lot while they were incarcerated from people who had lecture on topics. You see,
they've been put in the camp with them. So Housel didn't not all under at all, the Germans.
Well, in the war ended, and he went back, resumed his position in Oslo,
all the people who had been in the camp with him. He used the familiar form of the dress.
At that time, in Norway, there were two words for you, which is due in Z.
For D rather, I'm thinking of German there. So, he was D with,
of the old school. He was D when almost everybody that he didn't know, older people, especially,
they always refer to one of his D and them. Anyway, Housel, after I had been there for a year
and come back, I would always make a point at going to see Housel, because he was the professor.
He was, in effect, I think, a kind of a lonely man, because he had no family, had a living
housekeeper who served him his meals and did everything around. I had a beautiful house.
And one time when I came in, you know, I was always going to see him, and we would shake hands,
and he would immediately go to the board and show me what he was working on.
And then one time, when he was working at the board, and I had said D, and so on, he was saying,
D, he turned to me and he said, this is traditional one, Norway. He said, we have known one another
for a long time. I think it is time that we say due to each other. Now, a younger man could never
propose that. It had to be the older man. And, of course, I was knowing Housel, if I did,
I was quite honored by this, because here I was a foreigner. I was saying due to him,
where people that have been in his laboratory for years had not been in the camp, or anything,
we're still D. And these guys have been around for 20 years. He still said, D, you know.
But anyway, I guess I probably hit it off with him, because, of course, I was both Norwegian to it.
And he was so pleased that an American would come and learn Norwegian. See?
Anyhow, he invited Lisa and me to dinner at his house on time. We went back to Norway after we
were married. I've been there a couple of times on sabotic leaves afterwards. And one of these
guys, he invited us to dinner. We had a magnificent dinner at his house. It was all catered.
He had ordered it in from a catering outfit. I think I say F, actually. We're running a catering
outfit. And we had a very pleasant evening at Housel's house.
So, the people that didn't get that email were calling very often.
Pardon? People that didn't get the email were calling there.
Not very often. It's a little hard to tell. I was kind of one way, as I said,
you know, he always shook hands and said, how's Lisa doing? And he would ask me about there
also, it's the things he would call me Ken, but I never felt that he relished me calling him
Linus. And everybody had that feeling. I know he visited here when Earl Gilbert was chairman
alive and Gilbert referred to in his Linus. They talked to one another on that basis.
But I don't think Gilbert had really met him before. I just don't know.
Yes. I'll have him talked about that. I'll know. Well, here is a couple of incidents surrounding
this woman cool. I was asked by the pawlings with my then first wife to babysit the children while
they were off on a trip. The children are Peter, Linda, and Crollen. And they were early, early
teens. And Linus had finished and gone up to medical training was often Linus Jr. in a
white. And so we weren't required to do anything that kids ought to go to school. And so I'm
we're supposed to be there in the evenings. Make sure that they were all there and so on. And so
we did that. And they had this swimming pool.
The pawlings' house had two wings that came together like this. And people were fond of saying
I'm not sure whether it's true or not, but the angle between the wings was a hundred and nine
degrees and twenty-eight minutes, which is of course the angle of tetrahedral bond angle.
I don't know whether that story is true or not, but it certainly was very close to it.
Well, down in the little below it was the house was built slightly up and down below they had
a swimming pool. And the pawling kids, when their parents were away, were on the habit of going
around the chemistry department and inviting everybody up to a big party in a swimming pool.
And I remember this happening one time, the pool was full of people in the pawling showed up.
And in a short while, Eva Hillon came out and said, Linda,
your father and I would like to take a swim. And can you get these people out of here?
There was a hush that fell over the group and we vacated the premises very quickly.
One of the occasions when I was babysitting the kids, I heard a splash.
This is late at night and it's 11 o'clock and I've actually gone to bed and a bedroom
faced downhill. But I couldn't really see this swimming pool clearly. I think it's also some ripples in it.
And I heard this splash. And I wonder what the hell left was. But anyway, I didn't
bother to check and so on. And the next day there was no sign of anything.
And on the second day, I also heard this splash in the pool.
And again, I did nothing about it. But in the morning, I got up and I went into the kitchen and
made my breakfast and there was a strange man standing there in the kitchen, making breakfast.
And this was a guy.
Again, the name is hard for me to come by. But a long standing friend of the Paulings and Paulings
is mentioned by a name from the University of Texas. And I guess they asked him if he'd like to stay there.
Well, pardon me. Yeah, that's right, Jeffers.
So we introduced ourselves to each other. It turned out we've been living in this house.
Both of us for three days. And this was the first time our father crossed. I usually got up early
and sold it my then life. She went to work and I went to Caltech. And he was on vacation.
Came up later. So we've been living for three days. It's on the third day that I met this guy
in the same house. No, Jeffers, that's right. So that was the swimming pool.
What do you recall about this?
Elizabeth?
Oh, Peter, very, very vivacious. And Lind also. Krelon, let's though he was younger, quite a bit younger.
Well, I don't know how much younger, but at any rate, the two older ones.
They were almost unfettered. I mean, they were just in the everything in a good human way.
Very vocal both of them. Many years later, I went to Lisa and I went to Europe.
Peter at that time had gotten the position of the university of London. I guess it was.
And I called him and he met us in the sports car. By this time he had been pretty heavily
into alcohols and big problems. But at any rate, he was enthralled with my wife, Lisa,
you know, and boy, he couldn't. He was sideling up to her all the time and giving her all sorts of
compliments. You know, she was laughing at him most of the time. Peter had trouble with, I think he
had been divorced once. And I don't remember any of the details of his life. I only knew
at the end that he was totally incompetent and he had gone to Wales and was living in a small house.
I got a phone call from in a couple of times from the AL asking me about certain events
and his father's life as a fellow named Herman Branson who had given polling some problems regarding
priority and discovery and ideas and so on. Peter had told me, I knew Herman Branson
for the liner when they think about this and I didn't.
Well, Linda, I don't know a great deal about her life. I'll see what she did. I know
she met Bartley and when Bartley was a student at Caltech, polling was very impressed by Bartley.
I remember one occasion on a party when I was up there, he was asking Bartley some questions and
Bartley was answering them and I guess he was, he decided that he was the guy for his daughter.
Again, that's just my reaction about it. But Bartley was a nice guy and of course,
he lived in Pasadena and after we came to Caleralis, we didn't see them very much. But Bartley used to
make an annual or buy annual trip up to, as Linda put it, his glacier in Alaska is doing measurements
on a glacier flow and so on. And one time they stopped by and they stayed overnight with us and
at a very pleasant evening and Bartley could play the piano quite well and so
enjoyed sitting at our piano and playing it during the evenings. Afterward, Linda asked her
father for something that she could give to these and me as a token of appreciation and
I have a picture of polling together with the whole of the famous South African doctor and
after, yeah, I was five six. I was both of them in the picture, not what sent to me, I remember.
Well, we fight back on this period in Caltech, it's called the gold name, the Caltech and
the assistant kind of closing it away. That means that this is the gold name in Caltech.
Well, I guess it's properly termed because it was, you know, I was asked to give a lecture
a banquet talk one time at a meeting, a symposium in Texas and the topics suggested to me
was the golden age at Caltech. That was a title when we talked. So I dredged through all the archives
and found out quite a lot about various people and things. But the golden age was the age
of all this marvelous stuff that polling was doing in chemistry and people like Feynman and others
were doing in physics. And it was an environment that couldn't be more exciting to a young student
because you could almost literally hear a lecture each week by a Nobel Prize winner and some
subject or another visitors. I mean, I've heard lectures from people like Feynman who came from
Argon, I've attended lectures by Feynman, Carl Anderson was there, I've heard lectures by him
and I've heard lectures by people in chemistry who came through. So all this in the period
when I was a student and at the same time we knew there was a very active program in x-ray
crystallography going on. You voted to providing polling. I'm quite sure with the
fundamentals of structure that would enable him finally to formulate the alpha helix.
They published seven papers, you know, there's one of them's alpha helix. That's the famous one.
Then there's a pleated sheet and a number of other things that they published at that time.
So all of this was going on and we knew it. And when polling finally on veiled his
alpha helix, I remember that was a lecture of some showmanship and I told you about that.
No, well, Caltech built these space-filling models. You have some of them here in this special collection
of the alpha helix actually, I think. And I think it was that same model which was about this
high and it's got red white and black atoms all distributed through it representing the various
elements. You started to give a lecture on this and this thing was in the middle of the room
who was covered with a tall paper bag. So he was going to describe the structure, you know,
and as he went on, people's curiosity got, they were getting more and more in the edge of his sheets.
And he walked over and he pulled this thing up just about that far. And he put it down and he says,
oh, he said, I forgot to, and then people sort of Twitter, he did that once more, you know,
when people laughed. And the third time he took it off and showed it was everybody applauded,
you see, he was a great showman in that respect. I remember, by the way, a lecture he gave
a quantum mechanics, I took a course in quantum mechanics for me. The room is quite full of students.
They walked in one time and he carried a big book which was the nature, I'm sorry,
introduction to quantum mechanics by him and Brian Wilson. And the normal copy is about that thick,
but this is about that thick. It turns out that every facing page of the blank so he could write
notes and he would lecture from this. He would come in. One day he walked in and as he got inside,
there was the room was very wide and had blackboards and they were blackboards in those days from one
end to the other. He walked in, he hooked up a piece of chalk and there were three panels here.
He wrote on the upper left hand corner in 02 nitrogen dioxide. But I'm saying a word,
he went across, he began to lecture and he filled up the board over here and continues like
you're filled up the board over here. And as he got to the bottom, he had reached it once,
he says, now you take an NO2 molecule and he pointed to what he had already put there. People
a whole hour were wondering what was going to happen, but he had it at the precise location,
where he needed an illustration for what he had been talking about and they had it already written
up there. That's the kind of subtle humor that he used to impress the students.
He gave lectures to the undergraduate too and a lot of the undergraduates were a little bit
unhappy with this. The better ones were not. The graduate teaching assistants of which I was
one when I first came there were delighted with these lectures because they were what they were
looking for. But the students, he wouldn't pick out topics in the book and talk about them,
the books book are itself. But he would talk about things associated with and that were involved
at the perhaps at the cutting level of research. And he would talk about this. And that kind of
disappointed a lot of the students who wanted more explanation of what they were reading in the textbook.
So anyway, as TAs, we all like the lectures very much.
Well, there anything else about the topic here is that we should talk about.
I don't know. We've talked about a lot of the personalities there.
There were a lot of people I haven't mentioned that figure prominently, for example,
Jerry Donahue's a distinguished crystallographer and he happened to be in England in the same
laboratory where Watson and Crick were and he is said to have made a key observation to them about
the configuration that played a big role in there eventually coming to the right structure for DNA.
There are other personalities I haven't mentioned in chemistry. All sorts of names that run by,
but I don't have anything particular to say about them. I did some work with a guy named Vernon of
hockey from Switzerland. There's a very, very impressive man named Ed, your halberner. Do you know
that name Edgar King the Caltech also? He was Swiss. I think he was a Jew that left Germany in
agonist Switzerland just in the head of the Nazis and he was a superb scientist. He had a wonderful
sense of humor. He taught me how I found him at cheese fondue and he became very compactists.
Switzerland rose to the ranks. He became a distinguished professor and went to Balsal. He
inject on us were very close as families. They had apartments just a couple of doors away from each other.
Edgar died a few years ago and I had written to him when I knew that he was ill and I got a very
nice letter back from him and a year and a half later I was going to write again and then a fellow
named Ishen Mozart showed up to give a lecture in chemistry and I knew Ishen Mozart,
I'd given a lecture in Zurich and Halberner always spoke very highly of Ishen Mozart. So I said,
how is Edgar? He said, oh, he died. I was shocked. Absolutely shocked. And so I talked to
checked on it's about this running letter and so I hadn't heard at all. He said he apologized
to him directly and for not having let me know that then he said at the end Edgar became very
discouraged about something he had become ill. He had lost the leg and an accident. He probably
knew all about that. Oh, I'll tell you about the minute but he came very discouraged and he was in
the hospital and finally according to Jack and appears as if he just gave up and he died in the
hospital and in spite of them being very, very close to families. I said, well, how is Ruth doing?
That's Edgar's life. He says, I don't know. He says it's amazing because she retreated into herself
and has occupied herself solely with her children and grandchildren. We haven't ever heard a word
from her and he was terribly surprised because they were very close and she was an open friendly
woman with a great sense of humor and maybe it just struck her so hard that she didn't want to
have any connection with the past at all. I wrote her a letter and I never had a response.
Offering my condolences. Edgar was a very athletic guy, particularly in a rowing.
He was a single skull guy. He wrote on the leg and so right, but he was a bunny scientist and he told me
all this. He had been out on the town with his girlfriend and they had come by the house where
he lived. It was an apartment up here on his hill and the tram came down like this. One of these
brand new swiss trams that have all sorts of safety features on it. He was standing waiting for
the tram after having run upstairs to see whether the article he had been accepted had been published.
He was looking at a journal, you see. It had not been and he came back down. He was standing on the
platform with his then girlfriend and this tram came down the hill of the high rate of speed out of
my control and tipped over like this. I don't know whether his companions survived that and Ruth
was not she. I think that's true. I think she was killed, but at any rate his body went through a window
of the tram. But one leg was trapped underneath and they had to amputate it. So what I met him, he was
using a cane and the unapocetic device. He didn't use crutches. But he was brilliant at all sorts of
awards and Switzerland for a science later on. It's hard for me to think about these people knowing
them as I did and then thinking about what would have happened to them bad. So that's
about all I can tell you, you know, there are many, many minor details, but those are the highlights,
I'm on all.
Okay, you want to do more of this? Okay.